I think what's really interesting and I
was talking to Julie Bendle about this
yesterday and of course she's a woman
who's been involved in the left and
women's rights for decades now um I mean
there's always a joke amongst labor
women that all the old traditional trade
unionists were quite sexist and that
tradition was always quite sort of
freezing women out there's always been
jokes about uh women being found you
know the seats where they can't win
rather than the safe seats that's that's
a long labor tradition you know if I was
applying for my seat now I don't know
how that would go but it was completely
unwinable so I was left to get on with
it but the more high-profile winnable
seats have traditionally been women have
been discouraged from from going for
those or you know it's not quite your
time yet dear that kind of attitude